well labor has also claimed that
passengers would be a thousand pounds
better off if the party was to win the
general election that is after pledges
from Jeremy Corbyn to reinitialize the
network and to change the way that fare
Rises a cat well Liana it kind is from
the pressure group the campaign for
better transport and she's with us here
in the studio and Yana railways pretty
much central in the the campaign for a
lot of the time presumably you welcome
that focus but his nationalization do
you think though I thought certainly
there's a lot wrong with the current
rail system with fare rises year after
year after year while wages remain
stagnant but I'm not sure that
nationalization is the only answer or
indeed the answer something the campaign
for better transport supports is more
rail devolution so that would mean more
buddies like Transport for London or
Transport for Greater Manchester having
a say in controlling local transport
networks rail and bus and integrating
those together that would give greater
say and greater involvement and greater
accountability to passengers and after a
year in which especially southern
passengers have seen more fare rises for
really quite rubbish service I think we
need to see some sort of change we focus
a lot on things like the southern and
Gover and those problems across the
country as a whole how do you assess
though the state of our rail network are
we seeing pockets of terrible service
but generally it's pretty good what do
you make passenger satisfaction on the
railway has remained pretty steady at
about 80 percent but it's a real
patchwork across the country depending
on which train company you use but what
is across the board is that passengers
are fed up with fare Rises people feel
that every January when fares go up
they're getting fleeced and they're not
necessarily seeing that money delivering
more reliable trains or more frequent
trains we should just have a quick
listen to this this is some worse remark
el born president of GE one of the
biggest company
is in this country here's what he
thought when I spoke to Manila about the
idea of nationalization nationalization
scares the life out of me
in the context of we haven't had it at
that scale for that the scale has been
proposed for what pre 1980s and I think
you've got a generation of people the
Millennials who don't have no concept or
understanding of what of ever of an
evolving economy that would involve mass
public ownership alone oh I wonder do we
have a rather sort of rosy view of
British Rail and nationalized railways
because we lots people watching this who
go back a few decades and say it was
grim certainly since privatisation we
have seen more people choosing to use
the rail work network and more Freight
on the net rail network as well which is
great news taking lorries off the road
and freeing up road space for people who
really need to use it so in that sense
it's been a success however we don't
have a rail network at the moment which
works for everybody and enables people
to use the rail network from lower
incomes as well and one particular group
which is being badly failed by the rail
fares structure at the moment is
part-time in a flexible workers more and
more of us these days are choosing to
work maybe one day week from home
part-time or combine different jobs yet
to get a decent discount on your way
into work you really need to go for a
season ticket that works on a
old-fashioned Monday to Friday 9:00 to
5:00 working with Britain doesn't work
in that way anymore and we really need a
government to take the lead on this not
leave it up to rail companies but
introduce a fair deal for part-time
workers